and tonight we are learning more about a
motorcycle rider killed in a crash
william defalco came to the u.s from
cuba only to be killed when a driver ran
a red light that crash happened on allen
and anne road in north las vegas as
defalco was on his way to work christian
casadas joins us now live tonight from
that business and how his team is
remembering him christian
well brian and denise workers at this
car wash off craig and decatur tell me
that william defalco spent about two
decades working here just greeting
customers and helping keep operations
going every single day they also tell me
that one of his passions was that he
loved to come to work riding his
motorcycle and tonight you can see there
his picture shining bright on the
company sign as everyone is still
mourning
everybody knows him
even because we know when customers come
he already knows what kind of watch they
want you know like that's how close to
the customer with heavy hearts the team
at craig road car wash continue to push
through their day after one of their own
william tifalco was killed over the
weekend we've been working for 18 years
we have a routine together we come
together at the same time the openness
open the back today defalco's picture is
visible around the business a harsh
reminder charlie drake says about the
eerie saturday morning that changed
everything his colleagues tell us
difalco made a life in the u.s after
fleeing cuba and faced many challenges
along the way including surviving a
previous motorcycle crash that morning
just i know something is not right
because it's not him never late or he
called me i'm going to be on top of it
all right whatever unusual according to
north las vegas police 29 year old
thomas munoz was driving a sedan at a
high speed on allen lane saturday
morning and ran a red light colliding
with a motorcycle on ann road di falco
did not survive munoz was arrested and
faces five charges including dui
still drake says defalco's passion was
his bike kim is doing everything right
it's not even his fault he's running a
green light like everybody else
back out here live defalco leaves behind
a wife and two children now the manager
of this car wash also tells me the
entire team will be gathering at the
crash site this saturday evening for a
vigil they also tell me that they are
helping the family raise funds for the
funeral expenses christian gossett is
live local now